I remember the first time that I saw
people injecting drugs I just arrived in
Vancouver to lead a research project in
HIV prevention in the infamous Downtown
Eastside it was in the lobby of the
Portland hotel a supportive housing
project that gave rooms to the most
marginalized people in the city the
so-called difficult to house I'll never
forget the young woman standing on the
stairs repeatedly jabbing herself with a
needle and screaming I can't find a vein
as blood splattered on the wall in
response to the desperate state of
affairs the drug use the poverty the
violence the soaring rates of HIV
Vancouver declared a public health
emergency in 1997 this opened the door
to expanding harm reduction services
distributing more needles increasing
access to methadone and finally opening
a supervised injection site things that
make injecting drugs less hazardous but
today 20 years later harm reduction is
still viewed as some sort of radical
concept in some places it's still
illegal to carry a clean needle drug
users are far more likely to be arrested
than to be offered methadone therapy
recent proposals for supervised
injection sites in cities like Seattle
Baltimore and New York have been met
with stiff opposition opposition that
goes against everything we know about
addiction why is that why are we still
stuck on the idea that the only option
is to stop using that any drug use will
not be tolerated why do we ignore
countless personal stories and
overwhelming scientific evidence that
harm reduction works critics say that
harm reduction doesn't stop people from
using illegal drugs well actually that
is the whole point
after every criminal and societal
sanction that we can come up with
people still use drugs and far too many
died critics also say that we are giving
up on people by not focusing our
attention on treatment and recovery in
fact it is just the opposite we are not
giving up on people we know that if
recovery is ever going to happen we must
keep people alive offering someone a
clean needle or a safe place to inject
is the first step to treatment and
recovery critics also claim that harm
reduction gives the wrong message to our
children about drug users the last time
I look these drug users are our children
the message of harm reduction is that
while drugs can hurt you we still must
reach out to people who are addicted a
needle exchange is not an advertisement
for drug use neither is a methadone
clinic or a supervised injection site
what you see there are people sick and
hurting hardly an endorsement for drug
use let's take supervised injection
sites for example probably the most
misunderstood health intervention ever
all we are saying is that allowing
people to inject in a clean dry space
with fresh needles surrounded by people
who care is a lot better than injecting
in a dingy alley sharing contaminated
needles and hiding out from police it's
better for everybody
the first supervised injection site in
Vancouver was at 3:27 Carroll Street a
narrow room with a concrete floor a few
chairs and a box of clean needles the
police would often lock it down but
somehow it always mysteriously reopened
often with the aid of a crowbar I would
go down there some evenings to provide
medical care for people who were
injecting drugs I was always struck with
a commitment and compassion of the
people who operated and used the site no
judgement no hassles no fear
lots of profound conversation I learned
that despite on a map
trama physical pain and mental illness
that everyone there thought that things
would get better most were convinced
that someday they'd stop using drugs
altogether that room was the forerunner
to North America's first government
sanctioned supervised injection site
called insight it opened in September of
2003 as a three year research project
the Conservative government was intent
on closing it down at the end of the
study after eight years the battle to
close in sight went all the way up to
Canada's Supreme Court it pitted the
Government of Canada against two people
with a long history of drug use who knew
the benefits of insight firsthand Dean
Wilson and Shelley Tomac the court ruled
in favor of keeping insite open by nine
to zero the justices were scathing in
their response to the government's case
and I quote the effect of denying the
services of insight to the population
that it serves and the correlative
increase in the risk of death and
disease to injection drug users is
grossly disproportionate to any benefit
that Canada might derive from presenting
a uniform stance on the possession of
narcotics this was a hopeful moment for
harm reduction yet despite the strong
message from the Supreme Court it was
until very recently impossible to open
up any new sites in Canada there was one
interesting thing that happened in
December of 2016 when due to the
overdose crisis the government of
British Columbia allowed the opening of
overdose prevention sites essentially
ignoring the federal approval process
community groups opened up about 22 of
these de facto illegal supervised
injection sites across the province
virtually overnight thousands of people
could use drugs under supervision
hundreds of overdoses were reversed by
naloxone and nobody died
in fact this is what's happened at
insite over the last fourteen years
seventy five thousand different
individuals have injected illegal drugs
more than three and a half million times
and not one person has died nobody has
ever died at insite so there you have it
we have scientific evidence and
successes from needle exchanges
methadone and supervised injection sites
these are common-sense compassionate
approaches to drug use that improve
health bring connection and greatly
reduce suffering and death so why
haven't harm reduction programs taking
off why do we still think that drug use
is a law enforcement issue our disdain
for drugs and drug users goes very deep
we are bombarded with images and media
stories about the horrible impacts of
drugs we have stigmatized entire
communities we applaud military-inspired
operations that bring down drug dealers
and we appear unfazed by building more
jails to incarcerate people whose only
crime is using drugs virtually millions
of people are caught up in a hopeless
cycle of incarceration violence in
poverty that has been created by our
drug laws and not the drugs themselves
how do I explain to people that drug
users deserve care and support and the
freedom to live their lives when all we
see are images of guns and handcuffs and
jail cells let's be clear
criminalization is just a way to
institutionalize stigma making drugs
illegal does nothing to stop people from
using them our paralysis to see things
differently is also based on an entirely
false narrative about drug use we
been led to believe that drug users are
irresponsible people who just want to
get high and then through their own
personal failings spiral down into a
life of crime and poverty losing their
jobs their families and ultimately their
lives in reality most drug users have a
story whether its childhood trauma
sexual abuse mental illness or a
personal tragedy the drugs are used to
numb the pain we must understand that as
we approach people with so much trauma
at its core our drug policies are really
a social justice issue while the media
may focus on overdose deaths like Prince
and Michael Jackson the majority of the
suffering happens to people who are
living on the margins the poor and the
dispossessed they don't vote they are
often alone their society's disposable
people even within health care drug use
is highly stigmatized people using drugs
avoid the health care system they know
that once engaged in clinical care or
admitted to hospital they will be
treated poorly and their supply line be
it heroin cocaine or crystal meth will
be interrupted on top of that they will
be asked a barrage of questions that
only serve to expose their losses and
shame what drugs do you use how long
have you been living on the street where
are your children when were you last in
jail essentially why the hell don't you
stop using drugs in fact our entire
medical approach to drug use is upside
down for some reason we have decided
that abstinence is the best way to treat
this if you're lucky enough you may get
into a detox program if you live in a
community with suboxone or methadone you
may get on a substitution program hardly
ever would we offer people what they
desperately need to survive a safe
prescription
for opioids starting with abstinence is
like asking a new diabetic to quit sugar
or a severe asthmatic to start running
marathons or a depressed person to just
be happy for any other medical condition
we would never start with the most
extreme option what makes us think that
strategy would work for something as
complex as addiction well unintentional
overdoses are not new the scale of the
current crisis is unprecedented this
Center for Disease Control estimated
that sixty four thousand Americans died
of a drug overdose in 2016
far exceeding car crashes or homicides
drug-related mortality is now the
leading cause of death among men and
women between 20 and 50 years old in
North America think about that how did
we get to this point and why now there
is a kind of perfect storm around
opioids drugs like oxycontin percocets
and dilaudid have been liberally
distributed for decades for all kinds of
pain it is estimated that two million
Americans are daily opioid users and
over 60 million people received at least
one prescription for opioids last year
this massive dump of prescription drugs
into communities has provided a steady
source for people wanting to
self-medicate in response to this
prescription epidemic people have been
cut off and this is greatly reduced the
street supply the unintended but
predictable consequence is an overdose
epidemic many people who were reliant on
a steady supply of prescription drugs
turned to heroin and now the illegal
drug market has tragically switched to
synthetic drugs mainly fentanyl these
new drugs are cheap potent and extremely
hard to dose people are literally being
poisoned can you imagine if this was
other any other kind of poisoning
epidemic what if thousands of people
started dying from poison meat or baby
formula or coffee we would be treating
this as a true emergency we would
immediately be supplying safer
alternatives there would be changes in
legislation and we would be supporting
the victims and their families but for
the drug overdose epidemic we have done
none of that we continue to demonize the
drugs and the people who use them and
blindly pour even more resources into
law enforcement so where should we go
from here first we should fully embrace
fund and scale up harm reduction
programs across North America I know
that in places like Vancouver harm
reduction has been a lifeline to care
and treatment I know that the number of
overdose deaths would be far higher
without harm reduction and I personally
know hundreds of people who are alive
today because of harm reduction but harm
reduction is just the start if we truly
want to make an impact on this drug
crisis we need to have a serious
conversation about prohibition and
criminal punishment
we need to recognize that drug use is
first and foremost a public health issue
and turn to comprehensive social and
health solutions we already have a model
for how this can work in 2001 Portugal
was having its own drug crisis lots of
people using drugs high crime rates and
an overdose epidemic they defied global
conventions and decriminalized all drugs
possession money that was spent on drug
enforcement was redirected to health and
rehabilitation programs the results are
in overall drug use is down dramatically
overdoses are uncommon many more people
are in treatment and people have been
given their lives back
we have come so far down the road of
prohibition punishment and Prejudice
that we have become indifferent to the
suffering that we have inflicted on the
most vulnerable people in our society
this year even more people will get
caught up in the illegal drug trade
thousands of children will learn that
their mother or father has been sent to
jail for using drugs and far too many
parents will be notified that their son
or daughter has died of a drug overdose
it doesn't have to be this way
[Applause]
[Music]